[Music]
hey everybody and welcome back to the
ski resort I originally wanted to start
this video out with some Schleicher
music so I downloaded some DLC and
Flickr lead and all of that stuff but
eventually I was too much of a [ __ ] to
actually do that I don't wanna play with
YouTube's copyright system so I'm going
with some normally copyrights sort of
traditional Tyrolean folk music in the
background of this video instead which I
guess will do in its place but it's it's
a bit sad that we live in a society
where I can't just play copyrighted
terrible dance music out loud on my
youtube videos about planet coaster
anyway I figured it would be
thematically consistent because in
today's episode I'll be working on an
upper ski bar now I'll mostly be
focusing on this right here which is an
umbrella bar but I'll also build a
proper restaurant building next to it to
actually establish the atmosphere of
what one of these establishments would
have now I have to say right in advance
that I'm not actually that much of an
expert on this kind of thing and I know
that I've said that I've skied a lot in
my life
but pretty much every time that I've
been skiing was just with my parents and
we've only ever been to Austria and you
know it's nice to travel with your
parents but I wouldn't see myself
dancing on tables hammered and smashed
in an uppper ski bar as shopping flew
girls and singing the Hermes house band
with my parents so we never really did
any of that kind of thing my only upper
ski partying experiences actually from
the Netherlands Rotterdam has this funny
and frisky bar actually but yeah that's
about it aside from that my only skiing
experiences in Japan and while curry and
ramen for lunch is awesome it doesn't
quite have the same risky atmosphere
that European ski resorts have and then
I figured it would be you know very
important to feature in this ski resorts
since it would be supposedly somewhere
in Europe so yeah we're building this
and what exactly are we building well
the first of the Umbrella bar which is
probably the most recognizable structure
of an opera ski establishment that you
can
ever have it's just the kind of
architecture that screams terrible music
and drunk people and I think it's very
effective at doing that but it's mostly
effective at being a great temporary
structure because in reality it's just a
circle of simple walls in this case some
simple glass walls with in the middle a
giant umbrella that you can open and
just about cover the walls on the sides
to make a sort of makeshift tent and
then put some space heaters in it and a
whole lot of alcohol and you pretty much
have a party going so I figured it would
be very important to get one of these
iconic little structures on at least
somewhere of the mountain here sometimes
you'll find these actually halfway down
a mountain which I always kind of
questioned because you know that people
get drunk in these things and I wouldn't
want to like ski downhill after a couple
beers but then again I'm sure that most
of the time it's fine anyway but I
decided to not encourage drunk skiing
and put this thing all the way down at
the bottom of the hill down where the
lifts are and hopefully that will
prevent some people casually in the
future now that's pretty much it for the
umbrella bar it's a very simple
structure I will add some well minor
detailing inside although I have to say
it's not going to be much more than just
a few stools and beer bottles just
because I can't really come up with
anything else to really add in it it oh
it'll always feel like something's
missing because in reality it won't
really look realistic until there is way
too many people inside but that's
something that realistically won't be
very hard to do in Planet coasters so
it's just gonna have to look a bit empty
and deserted so I decided to start
working on the actual restaurant
building which this umbrella bar would
probably belonged to and this is going
to be quite a simple kind of Bavarian
Tyrolean kind of building a little bit
modeled after the farmhouses actually
but then in a way that it could be you
know remodeled after that it's not
exactly looking like a farmhouse and in
the front it'll have a lot of glass and
a terrace to really signify that this is
at the end of the day
a place where you can eat and drink
basically so yeah starting off with that
iconic overhanging roof houses from this
area always have very large overhanging
roofs with large wooden beams to support
it underneath it so I figured that's
just about the most important details to
get in place to make this a recognizable
structure and underneath all of that is
usually also wide balcony with a lot of
window boxes with flowers in them so
that's something that I didn't want to
miss out on either so building a quick
balcony here the wooden floor pieces is
actually what custom contents from the
Steam Workshop and I'm sorry but I can't
remember exactly what it was called but
just in case anybody wants to look it up
it's as a wooden floor piece somewhere
in the Steam Workshop it's not actually
in the game itself
so that's something to keep in mind but
the rest of this will pretty much all be
in game so here I'm adding the the large
glass facade to kind of make very clear
that at the end of the day even though
this building looks kind of traditional
it's still probably very modern and has
a kind of modern interior and a very
large front facade behind which the
actual restaurant would probably be I
should also add that I'm not going to
add interiors at least not in this
episode it's something that I couldn't
really fit in into an already quite long
episode but maybe that's something that
I might add at the end of the series
just kind of do it for all the buildings
at once we'll see if there's any popular
support for it I also have to say that I
really suck at interiors so that's part
of the reason why I'm always avoiding it
so I know that's that's a bit of a
weakness that I need to get over one day
but for now I'm just focusing on the
exteriors basically and yeah on the
second floor I'm also adding a lot of
glass all looks very fancy so you can
see that it's kind of a modern ish
building in the husk of a traditional
building and all of you haters of facade
ISM can start insulting me for this but
I kind of dig the look of this and as at
least in some of the larger ski resorts
you'll see this a lot some architecture
that looks very traditional and users
very traditional elements but at the
same time is larger and much more modern
and refurbished just to handle all of
the giant crowds and make everything a
bit more functional as well so I'm
adding a wing to the side here which is
theoretically where a lot of tables
would be I have to say this is going to
be kind of a small building for
restaurants so definitely going to be a
bit crammed in there but then again
that's also part of the real skiing
experience
stepping into restaurant and everything
is damp and musky and wet and it's all a
messy and chaotic that's just that's
part of the fun I feel like without that
you're not getting the real European
skiing experience so I only see this as
something positive I suppose
yeah and on the side here it's not
really going to be too interesting
otherwise again bringing back the very
much overhanging roofs I'm not actually
detailing the roofs in a way that I
sometimes do with all of the separate
wooden core balls making four separate
pieces of the shingles just because I'm
going to cover this with snow in the end
because realistically the trees are
covered with snow so some of the
building should have at least the thin
layer of snow on them as well so you
won't actually see too much of the roof
but just for the parts of the roof where
there's no snow I'm adding the roof
pieces anyway I feel like if you're
building a snowy roofs and you're just
putting down snow instead of the roofs
underneath it this just something's
wrong with you I'm completely that's
just me I also like to add actual
frameworks for buildings very often even
if you don't see much of the framework
in the end though I didn't do that for
this building
maybe I should at some point I'll think
about that anyway on the other side I'm
also adding a small wing on the side
just to make this building a bit more
interesting and balanced and at the end
of the day I feel like it already kind
of looks like the shape of a restaurant
building and I'm bringing it over here
to the to the umbrella bar just because
I wanted to build this thing in a
perfect grid position the 3d gizmo is
still
being very weird in this game and I am
so glad that for a planet Zoo it appears
to be fixed because it's just impossible
to move stuff around properly with the
3d gizmo sometimes so I like to build
buildings on a perfectly parallel grid
to the actual park borders so that I can
use the global 3d gizmo instead of the
the object based one and then rotate my
buildings as I want to put them in a
specific place I think that helps out
sometimes but in general it is nicer to
know exactly how you're building stuff
so yeah I can't wait for planet zoo to
actually have a functional 3d kiss mode
I still like the 3d gizmo it's it's an
awesome part of the game but God is it's
still broken anyway finally I'm adding
all of the foliage on the front with
those well I'm calling them window boxes
but I guess they're more like balcony
boxes which still have some flowers in
it it's it's winter so that's a bit over
the top but still you can't really get
rid of those flowers and I wanted to
have these boxes anyway and I think it
looks quite good so I'm ending this even
if it's a lot of efforts in a winter
time and just the small decorations some
planters and lanterns alongside the
umbrella bar as well because that
probably deserves some detailing as well
and finally I'm adding some awnings on
the side you can see me messing with the
Sun physician for a while there just to
try and get the lighting right just
because those awnings were looking a bit
strange in certain lighting conditions
but I think it looks fine in like this
right now and yeah finally building a
terrace right in front of the building
where the entire terrace with all of the
tables is going to be and I'm using
tables which I believe Ruby recommended
to me but I'm not entirely sure if this
is if this is a shout out to the wrong
person I'm sorry but anyway after the
last Jaeger horn episode or actually not
the last but the one where I built the
the Biergarten somebody recommended that
I used the actual beer garden tables
because in that episode I was kind of
using just the picnic tables in game as
a substitute for them but it turns out
that somebody made actual bee
like folding tables on the steam
workshop so I downloaded those and I'm
going to use them for this build because
well realistically you always have these
kinds of tables on terraces in ski
resorts because you can easily fold them
and pack them up when the season's over
or anything like that so it's very
practical you always see these all over
ski resorts so gonna have these tables
I'm adding some custom snow actually on
the terrace itself before I'm adding the
tables in though just because well
realistically snow would fall there and
for some reason I didn't want to just
terraform over it so if it looks a bit
strange that's why I ended up doing that
in the in the end but yeah here are the
tables finally and the way that I ended
up doing this is just putting them in
straight at first and then kind of
shuffling them around grabbing each of
the tables every now and then moving
them to different heights and positions
and rotations just to make it look like
in real life when these things kind of
move around a little bit and people are
shifting those benches and tables as
they're starting to sit down these
things are kind of annoying I hope is
find and they're a bit weird to maneuver
around but they're pretty much the most
practical thing for this kind of
situation so yeah what works works I
suppose and that is pretty much the
small biergarten here now I also
download some coca-cola bottles and some
beer bottles couldn't find much else so
there are only two things on the menu of
this restaurant
I'm afraid and there are only two things
ever on any of these tables but at least
I figured it would be better than
putting nothing on them at least it's a
bit of detailing so I decided to go with
that although it would have been really
cool to put some giant beer glasses on
the tables like you'll see in Bavaria
for instance oh and there's one thing
that I didn't add to the building that I
really felt I should have added which is
just a dormer I just can't go build a
building without any
a dormer at least somewhere I don't know
why I just always end up doing this and
ending that in was also a good reminder
to add some more support beams for those
giant overhanging roofs so there you go
I also really like the little spire
pieces and I'm sorry I don't remember
exactly who made these but I think
they're actually on the Steam Workshop
as well on a new name spire which I put
just on the edges of those roof gables
which just add a little nice touch to
these Gables you wouldn't really see
this in a ski resort in real life but
you know this is planet coaster I can
detail as much as I want and I thought
it would be a nice addition to these
buildings and finally I put a cheesy
year on the the front of the building as
if this building were really from 1954 I
think I really tonight I'm not entirely
sure it's really hard to tell I'm
watching from a very small preview but
yeah it's probably quite an old
restaurant I mean sometimes you do
really find really old restaurants in
certain ski resorts we've been skiing
for quite a while here honestly skiing
in general is something that's really
old and it's an interesting conversation
because it's one of these things that
kind of started appearing all over the
world I think there are a lot of claims
that skiing came from Scandinavia or
from the Alps but in reality I think
it's probably from just about everywhere
and apparently the oldest claims of the
invention of skiing are actually from
China from thousands of years ago where
it used to be your hunting practice and
in general it's interesting how a skiing
is one of those sports that is really
based on hunting since in a snowy
environment it is really the best way to
get around even on flat ground or just
slightly hilly ground it's much more
efficient than walking around in deep
snow
so yeah that's not quite an accurate
history not quite a very detailed
history but just as far as I remember
the history of skiing it is really
really old and it's been done all over
the world
for a really long time it's just that
only in the recent century
it's become a sports on the scale that
we know today which I think is
particularly caused by the intervention
of ski lifts and easier ways to move
around and the fact that people have
gotten rich enough to afford free time
and to afford skiing at least some
people because at the end of the day
skiing is still something that really
only middle-class people or Richard can
afford and still very expensive and it's
getting more expensive and it's getting
more difficult because climate change
and all that so yeah it's not something
that everybody can participate in for
sure at least everybody can build ski
resorts in Planet Coast I suppose if
that's any consolidation anyway I'm
getting way off topic so I'm adding the
back of the building here and I put a
tweet out where I said that this has
been one of these buildings where I
accidentally make the back look better
than the front which is a bit of a
controversial statement maybe maybe you
don't agree with that but definitely
when I built the back I tried to keep it
less detailed than the front and a bit
more simple but at the end of the day I
thought it looked better than the front
especially with the mountains in the
back so yeah here it goes my favorite
part of this build actually the bank is
kept much more simple and traditional
and mostly just had windows in places
where I felt it would make sense for the
restaurant inside and then it has kind
of the back door on the sides where I
suppose you could supply stuff or
whatever there might be a road on the
back or something like that I'm not
entirely sure how I'm going to work all
of that out but what I do know is that I
feel like from the back it's a slightly
better building just a slightly better
composition a bit less over the top with
all of those glass facades and it just
looks a bit more rustic I feel but I
guess you can be the judge of that
after the cinematic shots at the end of
the video as well now it's finally time
to add details inside the umbrella bar
all this time there's been snow inside
which kind of doesn't make that much
sense so I'm adding an actual floor in
now and the way that I was doing this is
oops this looks like a bit of weird
imagery forget
that anyway the way that I did this is
rotating some wooden floors twice
actually and the second time kind of
sinking them just below the other ones
to avoid having z-fighting
the rotation trick to make domes and
round shapes and things like that is
really neat but you always have to watch
out with Si fighting because if you have
too many textures that are exactly at
the same height everything just starts
looking like a mess so that's why I
ended up doing it like that and then I'm
building a very simple bar in the middle
but there really isn't much to this I
probably could have added some crates or
whatever if they existed but I'm just
detailing this to the minimum extent
then I would have to make this look
believable from the outside it's not
really per se meant to be seen from
inside but I think with all of these
tools the custom little stools by the
way which are literally just a wooden
post and an art piece and also the the
tables and some of the bottles and the
basic bar it generally looks quite
believable from the outside I feel so
that's basically why I did that now I
did forget one thing and I was already
almost going to record this commentary
at this point but then I realized that I
didn't have any skis or other equipment
outside of these buildings and that
really doesn't make sense because if
you're going here then you'll probably
be arriving with skis or a snowboard or
whatever other equipment you used to go
down a mountain and you want to leave
them somewhere so you often find wrecks
of skis and snowboards just outside
these things I couldn't find any
snowboard racks so pretty much everybody
here is skiing but yeah that's something
that realistically I really had to add
to these buildings because it's such an
iconic part of these buildings as well
to think that they're just kind of
placed in a sea of skis everywhere and
the slightly annoying thing about this
was that I did want it to look realistic
enough in terms of colors so I went and
individually gave all of these skis at
color it's a bit random but yeah at
least they almost all have and have a
unique color so that's a neat little
detail there that I spent too much time
on but I think in the end if you look at
the whole thing and you can see all of
these weird colors everywhere it just
looks a bit more realistic than seeing
all kinds of skis with the same color
patterns and I'm also putting some
helmets and stuff outside not sure who
would leave their helmet outside but I
guess it's something you could do anyway
that's it for this episode thank you
guys for watching and I hope to see you
in the next one
[Music]
you